a new film documents a sky news
investigation
and a 40-year battle by campaigners
against
pharmaceutical giant all about a pill
called primidos
used as a pregnancy test in the 1960s
and 70s
which parents believed caused
malformations to their babies in the
womb
an untold part of that story is the role
of a former prime minister does the
prime minister agree with me that
those families do now deserve justice
and there should be a chance to launch a
public inquiry into this terrible
scandal
prime minister my honourable friend has
raised an important issue
theresa may called for a review into
primitos after pressure from her own mps
and after reading a scientific review in
2017 which had found there wasn't a link
between the drug and malformations but
she felt
didn't make a convincing case certainly
when i looked at the report i felt that
it wasn't
the slam dunk answer that people had had
said it was
i explained to within my number 10 team
that i think that we should look at this
we should have a review on this
ultimately if the prime minister decides
it should go ahead then it will go ahead
did you get any pushback well i don't
think
those around the the healthcare system
were too pleased at the idea that there
was going to be some further work on
this
and on other issues because for many
years
they had been um saying no there's no
problem
one almost felt it was sort of women
being patted on the head and said
they're there dear don't worry you know
you're imagining it or it's it's not you
don't know we know better than you do
in july the cumberland review team found
that there was
avoidable harm caused by a failure to
regulate primitives
their report said victims should get a
government apology
and funding from the state and
manufacturer
reading it left lead campaigner mary
lyon almost speechless
that's more than expected
it's incredible that somebody that like
murray lyon
and other campaigners have held fast to
this campaign
despite all the many uh potential
setbacks they've had in terms of
of the government and and healthcare
professionals trying to stop them in
their tracks
well when i became prime minister the
first speech i gave on the steps of
number 10
was about social justice and the need to
deal with burning injustices
and i think the way that the campaigners
on primados
were treated was an injustice i think
it's important that the government looks
at the whole question of redress and
about how that redress
can be brought for four people
they've had an apology and that's
important but obviously lives have
suffered as a result
the manufacturer of primitives doesn't
feel responsible
shearing is now owned by bail which
insists the available evidence doesn't
support an association
between the drug and malformations back
in july the cumberland review team said
that bayer had a moral
and ethical duty to make amends to the
victims of primitos
now we've approached the company's chief
executive for an interview and he's been
unavailable
so we've come here to their headquarters
in leverkusen in germany
to see if he'll speak to us mr bauman
from sky news are you going to
compensate the victims of primitives
is bear going to pay them compensation
would you have any message to the
manufacturer
well i think they need to perhaps to
look at the history of this
at the time that primados was still
being prescribed
and people were still taking primos that
there was
a known risk a known potential risk
and ask themselves whether it was right
for that to have carried on
this prime minister will be remembered
for troubled brexit negotiations and
internal party battles over the eu but
she'll hope this and other inquiries
into hillsborough child sexual abuse and
contaminated blood
will also be part of her legacy jason
farrell sky news